bien vous avez compris ce n'est pas très
compliqué il suffit de suivre les
consignes que nous vous donnons par le
moyen de la télévision maintenant après
toutes ces explications une
démonstration
le petit film que vous allez voir
apparaître sur cet écran peut que vous
n'avez pas chez vous mais que j'ai chez
moi là juste devant les yeux là va me
dire ce qu'il faut faire j'ai déjà mes
rondes et coupé voyez il ya ici une
petite caisse qui doit aller now ou
chalets vous voyez mais comment faire
y'a pas d'escalier n'y a pas de treuil à
rien voilà le la caisse et là-haut et le
chalet
comment faire que dois-je faire le film
vannes le dis à tous les petits bonbons
le dire j'attends tout simplement
certainement des pointillés
voilà les pointillés auger pas le rond
de la bonne taille mon dieu
est-ce que ça va marcher cette
limitation de savoir je le mets là
suivant les pointillés pourra pas donner
de bord ont gelé ni vous est temps de
chercher le long de bonnes valeurs
j'ai collé montrond je découvre avec
vous là un voile à regarder c'est un
ballon regardez la caisse son vol
et grâce au ballon que vous avez misé
sur grand écran le miracle
ça c'est super voyez c'est facile et
poussée par le vent
le petit ballon va déposer doucement la
caisse sur le chalet sinon rien ça vous
riez je peux le faire donc vous pouvez
le faire
c'est toujours ça alors tout au long de
l'été nous vous expliquerons comment
marche ce tte l'ectaa qu voyez les
petits pointier sont revenus ça veut
dire qu'il faut que j'enlève ma feuille
de plastique et l'image va redevenir
normale telle qu'elle doit être
enfin bref tout l'été voilà l'image
finale tout l'été vous allez apprendre à
faire fonctionner le télé taktika et
nous jouerons ensemble au mois de
septembre